So here at Nogales
we didn't see a lot of fentanyl pills,
a lot of methamphetamine also.
Every once in a while,
we do get heroin and cocaine.
But right now,
the way that these packages are wrapped,
it looks like possible meth.
Okay, so now we're just going to open
one of the first packages
depending what we see
in terms of tests, we're going to be using
And if from the initial,
it looks like they're blue pills.
So these are possibly fentanyl pills.
This is our rapid response
test for fentanyl.
I'm going to extract the pills
from the package
and the swab bit with the solution
and then using the test strip,
it's going to determine
whether it is
fentanyl responsible for it or not.
It'll give you one line.
If it's positive,
we'll give you two lines of it's negative.
It's a red line that's going to come out
So that red line right there
in the first package,
we just popped over and that's positive.
So the next test right now
will open some packages,
make sure that they're
the same contents are different.
If it's different tested
with different type of test.
So right now
on the opening, we just see that it looks
a second to the same, the first package.
So we can assume
that is the same kind of narcotic
All the substances look the same.
They are all small pills.
Even in the packages look different.
They have the same aura narcotic inside
conceal inside.
Now we need to weigh them
to see how much narcotics we have
1.86 kilograms.
It was a good day whenever you are able
to seize any type of narcotic.
The further it leaves Nogales,
the more pricier it gets.
So it's always a good day when we take
these narcotics out of the streets
here in CBP. It's a team effort.
We used a lot of different tools today.
We had our primary officers.
We had our canines
We also had different other methods
of search and with the use of all that.
We're able to secure some narcotics today.